all right welcome everyone if you're
gathering from the outside halls come
join us i realize it's early on a
saturday morning
we're grateful you're here
uh you're you it's how we separate the
true people interested in data from
those who aren't right it's are you
going to come on a saturday morning to
listen to your peers talk about some
cool things they're doing in the world
of data my name is travis oliphant i'm
chair of the num focus foundation which
is one of the organizers of the pi data
conference series we're thrilled you're
here very very grateful to facebook for
hosting us this year they've been a
tremendous host very excited about all
they've done i'd like to actually turn
some time over to uh guy bayes
who's chief data geek head of enterprise
business intelligence they do a lot of
data stuff here at facebook and so he's
gonna give us some more words
hey you guys welcome
boy i was just telling my team i've
never seen so many data geeks up at 9
a.m before in my entire life
it's incredible neil is like passing out
on his seat though
so anyway welcome to facebook we're
really excited to have you here and
we're really glad to finally get a
chance to give something back to the pi
data community so i really hope you
enjoy your time and you know get a
chance to network with everyone and
learn all sorts of cool stuff
so i'm not going to waste too much of my
time your time letting me talk i'm going
to introduce you to birch arpat who is
the senior manager of quantitative
engineering
python master and
has some phds from stanford and stuff
like that so anyway this guy does like
crazy stuff every week and i'm sure
you're gonna really love hearing what he
has to say birch
you